welcome to another famous Friday where I
look at famous entrepreneurs and help
you model their success so you can
achieve rapid business growth for your
company
today's theme is have guts if you want
to have success with your business then
you need to have guts you have to bet on
yourself you have to be willing to step
outside your comfort zone you know that
safe little cocoon where it's warm and
secure and step outside to reach for
something great you're gonna have to
step outside and breach that comfort
zone of yours if you want to change the
world and do something amazing so one of
my favorite stories is about Bill Gates
and when he was a student he was in
Harvard and he didn't really like
Harvard and he spent most of the time
playing poker and playing computer games
and one day he saw on a magazine cover
the first microcomputer called the
Altair by a company named MIT's and he
thought you know what this is my
opportunity I want to be my own boss I
want to have my own business I want to
be in software I don't want to be going
to Harvard and so he called up the
company and he said you've got a great
new computer it's gonna need software
and I have developed a version of basic
which was the most popular programming
language at the time for the Altair it
was a complete lie
you can't even seen the Altair before
let alone touch the line of code but he
called them up and said he had and they
said wow that's great we'd love to have
you come down here and show it to us and
she said no problem and so then he got
his friend Paul Allen and they started
working together on trying to create
basic for the Altair they had to start
now actually delivering what they said
they could do and they didn't even have
it Altair to work on so they started
using other computers and piecing it
together and they were on their flight
to New Mexico the GoSee myths the
company that made the Altair and still
tinkering with it on their trip and they
got there and they weren't even sure if
it was gonna work
because they had never tested it on an
I'll tear and they put the software in
and
it actually worked and they got the
contract and Bill Gates dropped out of
Harvard and started Microsoft now MIT's
went on a business shortly after but it
didn't matter because Bill Gates had
gone on to sell software to other
companies and other computer
manufacturers now I'm not saying you got
a lie
okay you don't think go lie to get your
first customer you don't have to cheat
people but what you do have to do is
have guts and you got to take a bet on
yourself and you got to believe and you
have to know that what you have is a
value to people that you can help people
and if you feel in your heart that you
know a job isn't for you you want to be
your own boss you want to have your own
business you want to put your mark on
this world you've got to take guts to go
out and take that first step and launch
your business even if it's part time
launch and if you're ready in your
company and your flatline and you're not
getting growth you know you started and
now you're just like this then you've
got to do something to step outside your
comfort zone because what you're doing
right now day in day out it's not enough
you've got to stretch yourself you've
got a track or something new you have to
have guts believe those are watching
like the video you can support me by
clicking on the link in the description
leave a comment let me know you think
and click on my face to subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon